- Ròu is meat.
(speaking in Mandarin) Duì.
Okay. (bleep)? Is it (bleep)?
No, no, that's not what you said.
- You said something else.
- What did I say?
(bleep)
(screen swooshing)
- Hey guys, it's Katie,
and I'm here with my friend, Jasmine.
And today she's going to be teaching me
one of her favorite recipes
that she ate growing up.
(speaking in Mandarin)
(upbeat music)
(text swooshes)
(screen swooshes)
- So,
(Katie laughs)
I will give you a few lifelines.
One, Google it.
Two, phone a friend, being my brother.
And number three, phone my mother.
- Ooh, that will be fun.
- Katie, do you know any Mandarin?
- No.
- Any other languages?
- I took German and like,
I've done this with Anaket in India.
And he spoke Hindi
(Katie Coughs) but like-
- Oh my God.
- I really don't know.
- Okay, do you want to learn some basics?
- Yes, please. I desperately, please.
- Okay, should I count to five?
- Yes.
- Five? Okay.
- Just like a child.
- One.
- Yī.
- Two is Èr.
- Èr.
- An easy way to remember is
(imitates seesaw squeaking)
- So, one, two,
there's two people on
this side of the seesaw.
That's why it's going
down 'cause it's heavier.
- Sure, whatever helps you.
(Katie laughs)
- Yī, Èr.
- Sān.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Sì.
- Wǔ.
- Ooh!
- Wŭ.
- Wǔ.
- Wǔ. Ooh.
- It's like Wŭ.
- Wǔ. Wǔ!
- Wow.
- Oh, okay, so it's like a check mark.
- Yeah, yes! Yes.
- Wǔ.
Do I sound like a child
to you when I do it?
- You sound American.
(Katie laughs)
- Like an American baby.
(screen wooshes)
- I will go over the ingredients one time.
- Yes. You're gonna do this,
we're going through
this one time and then,
that's it.
- One time it's on your own,
you heard the lifelines, you
use them when you need them.
- Okay, I'm ready.
- Okay.
(speaking in Mandarin)
(attempting Mandarin)
- Hmm.
- Okay.
(speaking in Mandarin)
(attempting Mandarin)
Garlic.
- Okay, garlic.
- For this one, Furikake,
there's actually not a
word for it, I don't think
but I grew up calling it
(speaking in Mandarin)
- So rice seasoning is
- Yeah, which kind of means
like sprinkle, sprinkle.
(speaking in Mandarin)
- Yo! Yo?
- No.
- [Katie] No.
- Wait, yóu is oil.
- Yóu.
(speaking in Mandarin)
- Green onions. (speaking in Mandarin)
I'm just helping myself remember.
- Yeah, can you walk me through that?
- Those are drumsticks and I don't know,
they're just making,
- They're making,
(both imitating drum beat).
(both laughing)
(speaking in Mandarin)
- Sesame oil.
- Mǐ is rice.
- Me love mǐ.
- Me love mĭ too.
(both laugh)
(speaking in Mandarin)
- Pepper?
- Yes.
(speaking in Mandarin)
- Ooh, it's spicy.
Hey, watch out!
(speaking in Mandarin)
- Pepper's not spicy.
- It's kinda spicy.
I'm trying to help
myself remember, alright?
- You ready?
- I forgot everything before mĭ.
(bell dings)
(speaking Mandarin)
Okay. I heard mĭ.
(both speaking Mandarin)
Is that like wash?
(speaking in Mandarin)
Yes!
(both speaking in Mandarin)
You know what? That
yes, it sounds like duh.
- No duh!
- Like, doy!
Oh, but how much?
(speaking Mandarin)
(repeating words)
Is that, okay.
(speaking Mandarin)
- Yī, one?
(speaking Mandarin) Two.
(speaking Mandarin)
Two cups.
Ah!
(speaking Mandarin)
Okay. So oh, water, to wash.
(Both speaking Mandarin)
- I'm gonna rinse this out.
I'm going to pour this out
and do this a few more times,
just to get any excess
starch off the rice.
(speaking Mandarin)
No doy.
(both laughing)
Rice rinsed, ready to go.
(speaking Mandarin)
(imitating electrocuting shock)
Rice cooker!
(speaking Mandarin)
(Katie laughs)
We should just play charades.
(both laughing)
So, I'm gonna put this,
I haven't used a rice
cooker in a long time.
(speaking Mandarin)
Get it all, you use it all the time.
You use a rice cooker all the time.
- Wow.
- You're just like, every
day. You use it every day.
(speaking Mandarin)
I think that was good.
Oh, you got to put rice.
You got to put water in this.
(speaking Mandarin)
- Sān! Sān is four.
Sān no. No, no, no.
EE-ER (making see-saw sound)
Sān is three. It's three!
(speaking Mandarin)
(mimicking words)
- Shuǐ.
(speaking mandarin)
- Water goes in
- Shuǐ.
Shuǐ is water.
- Dui.
- Yes, shuǐ is water.
(speaking Mandarin)
(intro music)
- Now (speaks in mandarin) beep, beep.
- We're going to let it go till it beeps.
- Dui.
- But like, I need to put
some time on it. Right?
(speaking Mandarin)
- Just press start?
An hour? This says an hour.
Next.
(speaking Mandarin)
(exhaling heavily and laughs)
Okay, I'm trying so hard.
Say it one more time.
- (speaking Mandarin) Wǎn.
- A bowl. A new bowl.
(speaking Mandarin)
(crashing sound effect)
- Soda.
- (speaking Mandarin)
- Drink
(speaking Mandarin)
- Oh it's a Bo- soda. Boba.
(laughs)
(speaking Mandarin)
- Ahhh!
- Shuǐ. Shuǐ.
- Shuǐ, water.
(speaking Mandarin)
- Yes a cup of water. We need more water!
(laughing)
No, no, no, no, no. Oh, oh cup.
- Dui, Bates. D E E
- Yī one, I got one.
- Bay.
- One cup, one cup, one cup, one half.
It's half a cup. It's half a cup.
- Yī.
- Half a, one cup
- (both) Yī.
- One and a half cup.
- Dui.
(screams)
- Okay so, cup and a half of.
(speaks mandarin)
- Sure. You use the lifeline.
I feel I've stayed on this too long.
- Okay.
- I'm going to Google.
- You're going to Google it.
- I'm using Google and everyone.
(speaks mandarin)
- Foot beat.
- Google.
- Ground beef, a cup.
(speaks mandarin)
- Two tablespoons.
- Of
(speaks mandarin)
- Which I think is soy sauce.
Only because, I-
- Dui.
- Okay, okay.
One, two.
(speaks mandarin)
- Is that Sesame oil?
Act out.
- Oh, brown sugar because you love Boba.
- Dui.
- Boba has brown sugars.
- Dui, dui, dui.
- Dui. Okay, I only have half tablespoons.
So I'm gonna do four of these. Huh?
(speaks mandarin)
- So it's like a lot, two tablespoon.
(mimics mandarin)
Garlic.
- Dui.
I have to mince it.
(speaks mandarin)
- Two tablespoons.
- Dui.
Two tablespoons of this into that.
Yes, yes, yes. Okay.
(speaks mandarin)
- Now two tablespoons.
(Katie mimics mandarin)
(speaks mandarin)
- Too much, it's like so
much. It's like so much.
(speaks mandarin)
- What if I like it?
What if I like a lot of it?
(speaks mandarin)
- Okay. How are we supposed
to really thin? Sorry.
- Dui.
- So we are dicing. Now we're mincing.
Okay. Wait. Let's do it again.
My eyes are watering.
We all cool. I'm not crying.
I was like, cool.
- It's the gun-ion.
- It's the gun-ion. (laughs)
- Liǎng
- Two.
(speaks mandarin)
- (imitates mandarin) Tea.
- Tea times.
(laughs)
(speaks mandarin)
- Two tablespoons.
Tea.
(speaks mandarin)
Oh, watch out.
No.
I'm really bad at this.
(speaks in mandarin)
- Two tablespoons.
- Two teaspoons.
(speaks mandarin)
- Oh my God. Two teaspoons.
(imitates mandarin) Which is sesame oil.
- Dui!
- Yes, cuz' yo is oil.
(speaks mandarin)
Dui.
- You know that I love pepper.
(speaks mandarin)
(Katie mimics mandarin)
- Oh, mix, mix, mix.
(speaks mandarin)
- Oh, we're going to chill this,
we are gonna marinate it all.
- Dui.
(speaks mandarin)
(Katie mimics mandarin)
- Oh, let's get a pa, a frying pan.
- Dui.
(speaks mandarin)
(imitates mandarin)
- Half? Like medium heat.
- Dui.
- Medium heat. I think I just
really in your body language.
- Oh, (speaks mandarin)
- Oil.
- Wow.
Go really whole, okay. (speaks mandarin).
- Get the meat?
- Dui.
- Yes, okay. Okay.
(speaks mandarin)
- Break it up.
Get it hotter.
- Dui.
- Turn up the heat. Okay.
I'm turning up the heat.
(speaks mandarin)
- Turn it. Take it off heat.
- Dui.
- Yeah, okay.
(speaks mandarin)
- Rice. Rice is Meat.
- Yes. The rice is done. You wanna see?
(speaks mandarin)
- Take it out!
- Dui.
- Yeah!
(speaks mandarin)
(Katie mimics mandarin)
- The rice in the bowl.
- Dui.
(speaks mandarin)
SASA. Cause it's like shake, shake.
- Dui, Dui, Dui!
(speaks mandarin)
- Oh, soy sauce, soy sauce.
- Dui, Dui, Dui.
- Okay, half a tablespoon.
(speaks mandarin)
- Sesame oil, half a tablespoon.
- No, that's not right.
(speaks mandarin)
- A teaspoon, half a
teaspoon, half a teaspoon
of oil as well. Okay.
(speaks mandarin)
- Si four, I know you're saying four,
- Fun J E and then one,
take four, make it one.
(speaks mandarin)
- Four and make it half.
A quarter of quarter.
- Dui.
- A quarter, okay.
(speaks mandarin)
- A quarter cup.
- A quarter tablespoon?
(speaks mandarin)
A quarter, (laughs) what am I having?
A quarter teaspoon.
- Dui.
- Okay. A quarter teaspoon.
(speaks mandarin)
- Salt. They kind of have that soul.
- Mixi mix.
- Dui, Dui, Dui
- Woo. This is going to be so good.
(speaks mandarin)
- Near row. Yamunda.
(laughs)
- That's not a word, she says.
- Jumanji.
- Jumanji (laughs)
I heard y'all rule.
(laughs)
I think I need a lifeline.
So we're calling your,
I'm gonna call your mom.
Hello?
- Hi mom.
- Yes.
So Katie needs help.
- Hi.
- Oh, Hi Katie.
- Ma. I'm going to say it in Mandarin.
And then you're just going to tell Katie
what the translation is.
- Okay.
(speaks mandarin)
- In ground beef.
- Add in ground beef.
I should've thought of that.
Thank you.
- (both) Okay, bye.
(speaks mandarin)
Mix it, be a... sorry.
Take a quarter cup of the mixture.
(speaks mandarin)
I have another one. I have one left.
- [Alvin] Hello!
- Hey Alvin.
- [Alvin] Okay.
- Hi!
(speaks mandarin)
- [Alvin] Put it on your hand.
(Katie laughs)
- Thank you.
- That's it?
- Yeah.
- Okay, bye Alvin.
(speaks mandarin)
- Put it on my hand.
- Dui.
(speaks mandarin)
Just make a ball?
- Dui!
- Yay, because I said ball
earlier in your, if you were like, whoa.
(speaks mandarin)
Make a bun.
Continue making balls.
(speaks mandarin)
Just use the rice.
- Dui.
- Okay. So I'm just going
to keep making balls.
I finished. I got my balls.
(speaks mandarin)
(Katie mimics mandarin)
Myo is sesame seed oil.
(speaks mandarin)
Rewind, reverse.
Reverse it?
(speaks mandarin)
The opposite of myo.
Sesame seeds.
- Dui.
- It's like oil, it just sesame seeds.
Yes. Okay, okay, okay. Yes. Ah
(speaks mandarin)
Good job.
You're perfect. They're perfect.
Beautiful.
(speaks mandarin)
They're beautiful.
I'm beautiful.
(speaks mandarin)
We're all beautiful.
- SASA! This is my favorite because
the only thing I can remember.
Yay! Wait already finished?
(speaks mandarin)
- How do you say: All done!
(Katie mimics mandarin)
- Alright, we are done, let me get mine.
- Ooh, they look the same, but different.
- [Jasmine] Same, same but different.
- Yours look better.
- No, yours are so beautiful.
- My meat chunks are thick.
- They are, but that
means some juicy bites.
- Yeah. What is this called?
- These are Korean rice balls.
They are called Jumeokbap.
My Korean is not as good as my Mandarin,
so I couldn't have done
it in Korean. Not yet.
Not yet. Still working on it.
- Jumeokbap?
- Ju-meo-kbap
- Rice ball, their rice balls.
- But they look delicious.
- My mom would make
these for school lunches
or these would be like hiking foods.
- Oh cool.
- They're really easy to
put in like a Ziploc bag.
And then you can like push
them up in your Ziploc bag.
- I want to try that.
- Yeah let's eat.
- Let's do it.
Do you want to try mine
first? Yes, please.
- Cheers.
- So good.
They're a little sweet. I guess.
- Brown sugar.
- Brown sugar in the beef.
- The meat. Pretty much a
Korean barbecue marinade.
- That's so good.
- This is great.
- I did a good job?
- I'm just going to.
- It's kind of deceiving right? The size.
- It's like a lot.
Let's try yours. Okay.
Let's see if I got anything
wrong with measurements wise.
- Cheers.
- It tastes the same.
- I like that your beef is smaller,
because it's more dispersed
through your out your
bite, better balance.
- And you don't even have
to add the ground beef.
You're going to add some vegetables.
You can put a little like
avocado mash in the middle.
- Ooh, this is genius,
this is a good snack.
- It's like a sandwich.
- Yeah.
- You have a million different sandwiches.
You can make a million different
kinds of rice balls all up
to your own preferred.
- I love it. I'm going
to start doing this.
I feel like, I've sea weed.
- Do I?
- Yes, actually right in the middle?
- Everywhere.
(both laughs)
I'm just kidding, I'm just kidding.
- Jasmine, thank you so much for A,
teaching me this hole recipe.
For teaching me Mandarin.
I mean, I'm not fluent.
But I feel like I learned a lot today.
- You did great.
- How do I say, how do we say goodbye?
(speaks mandarin)
(Katie mimics mandarin)
- I still have rice on the hand.
Honestly, we just say bye-bye.
- Bye-bye.
(outro music)